[موسيقى]
رغبه اوروبيه لم تعد خفيه لتغيير التوجه
السلبي في علاقاتها بالصين خلال السنوات
الاخيره لكن في المقابل على الصين ان
تتبنى توجها مسؤولا في بناء هذه العلاقات
هذه الكلمات وزير خارجيه الاتحاد الاوروبي
جوزيف بوريل الذي اقر بشكل مفاجئ باعتراف
التكتل باهميه بكين ودورها في حل القضايا
الاقليميه
موقف بوريل هذا اعتبر متناقضا لماذا لان
الاخير وقبل شهر فقط صرح بوضوح ان الصين
لا يمكن ان تكون وسيطا في الحرب باوكرانيا
ولكن يبدو الان ان اوروبا بحاجه الى الصين
من اجل الاقتصاد والسلام على حد سواء وفقا
للتفسير الغربي فاقتصاد الاتحاد الاوروبي
يواجه تحديات ضخمه في اعقاب الوباء
والتضخم واسعار الطاقه المرتفعه والديون
المتصاعده ووفقا لمجله جلوبال تايمز فمن
المهم الان اكثر من اي وقت مضى ان يحافظ
التكاتل الاوروبي على تعاون تجاري مع
الصين التي اصبحت طريقا حيويا للخروج من
ازماته الاقتصاديه كما يحتاج الاتحاد
الاوروبي الى تعزيز علاقات مع الصين كي
يتحرر من القبضه المهيمن الولايات المتحده
كما تقول المجله
[موسيقى]
على الصعيد السياسي فان اوروبا التي
اراقتها الحروب الطويله تحتاج الى دعم
الصين للمساعده في حل تفوضي لنزاع الروسي
الاوكراني وهذا معبره عنه وزيره خارجيه
المانيا انلينا بيربوك التي زارت مدينه
تشانجين الساحليه الصينيه حيث قالت انه لا
توجد دوله اخرى لها قوه اقناع وتاثير اكبر
على روسيا لوقف الحرب اكثر من الصين ولكن
انفتاح الاتحاد الاوروبي تجاه الصين جاء
بشروط خفض التوتر بمضيق تايوان وصنع
السلام في اوكرانيا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات